and our next speaker is ahmed el-alui
who is currently a postdoc at
stanford and he is our richard carp
research fellow in the property program
thank you prasad um so here yeah this
this talk will be about
optimization of random functions um just
this is uh let me explain like at a high
level why would we
care about these things so the main two
questions we want to understand is
trying to optimize highly non-complex
and combinatorial functions in high
dimensions and also
a related question is to sample from
high dimensional distributions that are
not necessarily nice
and so worst case theory here tells us
that all of these problems the most
interesting cases are np
hard however we can see that in practice
a lot of these problems are solved in a
routine like can you
scroll to the next slide please
so right so in applications we have a
prevalence of
non-convex the previous one thanks
previously
thank you so we have a prevalence of
non-convexity with a large number of
parameters but as i was saying large
instances are routinely solved with
various heuristics on a daily basis
so maybe an explanation is that real
world instances are rarely worst case
right
and the next plausible explanation is
that noise in the data and randomness
have a smoothing effects that
just smooth out the edges of these hard
problems and make them nice so
the main high level motivation here is
to understand average case instances and
how
hard they are so a very simplistic model
is to consider random functions so
please next slide
right so let me define these these
models that come from physics they're
called spin models and these are very
roughly speaking families of random
functions on the hypercube plus minus
one
to the power n and they're gaussian so
these are just two examples that i
showed you here so the first
one is just a quadratic that depends on
uh interactions between just two single
sides which are sigma sigma i and sigma
j
and the strength of this interaction is
modeled by this random variable this
coefficient gij which i'm going to
consider to be gaussian and iid they're
all independent mean zero variance one
the other example which we call the
three-spin model is almost the same
thing except that we have a three-body
interaction instead of a two-body
interaction so these are
polynomials the first one is of degree
two the second one is the
of the grade three and the coefficients
are all uh
random so the problem here is to find
approximate mesomizer maximizers and
polynomial time so this is the question
of either of these two problems by the
way you can
consider polynomials of higher degree
just by following this idea of just
adding
monomials of higher degree and then you
can combine them linearly and
the question doesn't change you can
still ask the same question so the main
results here that i want to discuss is
that basically for the first problem the
answer
the answer is yes conditional and a
certain conjecture in mathematical
physics that's called
full or continuous replica symmetry
breaking i won't go into that
the second one is no you can't do it at
least that's what we believe
but we can't provide an algorithm that
runs in polynomial time and
that approximates the solution to the
currently best approximation ratio
this is the best approximation ratio
that is currently known for polynomial
time algorithms
let me go to the next slide
all right so we can actually implement
these algorithms these are very
tractable you can implement them in your
computer and everything
and they scale pretty well to large
dimensions so the first
uh plot here on my left hand side
so the objective value is e opt and you
can see that with the algorithm as
n increases you tend to that value
pretty pretty quickly
on the other hand on my right hand the
plot is for the problem for the
and the optimal value is up there above
1.81
but the algorithmic value that we can
achieve is e
out which is slightly below and we this
is for for now this is the best
algorithmic
uh value that is achievable by a
polynomial time algorithm and we're
interested in
trying to understand this gap and try to
bridge it by other means or try to under
or
maybe prove that no algorithm can can
can do better
and thank you this is the end of my talk